to be wife husband and wife it's the
best that was Liam Hemsworth in January
2019 just weeks after tying the knot
with Miley Cyrus fast forward to August
10th and Miley's rep released a
statement revealing she and Liam are
going their separate ways feels lucky to
be with someone like her on Monday Liam
addressed the split on his Instagram
confirming he and Miley recently
separated he wrote quote I wish her
nothing but health and happiness going
forward the actor also called the
situation a private matter and said he
has not and will not be making any
comments to the media you may have seen
these pics floating around over the
weekend Brody Jenner's ex Caitlyn Carter
on vacation with Miley loving on each
other but according to a source who
opened up to et on Monday the two former
couples are actually doing fine the
source said that Brody is not only still
friends with Caitlyn but also Miley and
Liam adding that Brody spoke to all of
them separately over the weekend quote
he still cares deeply for her and his
friendships with them he wants everyone
to be happy and live their best lives
Brody playfully acknowledged the pics on
social media over on his Instagram he
joked that pics of him and Liam holding
hands on the beach who were coming soon
Miley even wrote back go take a nap in
your truck and cool off what's it like
sleeping in a car I came home to a
psychopath
yelling and screaming at me because I
came home at a certain time
et sat down with a couple in May ahead
of the Hills premiere they opened up
about exposing their personal lives to
the public and showing their
relationship on camera reality TV in the
past has not been great for
relationships in general it can be very
trying to like it it not helped us but
it brought us closer together because it
was kind of like us against the world in
moments when filming the show sure so
you get other people chiming he's
already planning on it not working up